i see a guy like shaq the diesel the big
aristotle he's shattering backwards he's
shackling a fool
but all i want to know is what he do
with the money
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is
shaq was a beast a hall of famer he ate
defenders like
biscuits the guy was so powerful that
after games they would have to remodel
the entire court
and despite some early financial
mistakes he was able to transition his
dominant
baller mentality into a money-making
powerhouse
and check this stat 60 percent of nba
players go
broke within five years of retirement
and shaq
almost fell into that trap shaq blew the
first million dollars he made
from the nba within 30 minutes shaq was
on his oprah
he bought a new mercedes he got matching
cars for his mom and dad
he got a new house for grandma he got
iced out in jewelry he said give me all
that
before even put it on an nba jersey his
banker immediately called him up and
said
what the are you doing shaq do you
want to end up living in your new car
shack got the point and it paid off big
time
now the big diesel is rumored to have a
net worth of 400 million
dollars but when asked to comment on his
nine-figure fortune shaq says
my mother would be disappointed if i
talked about numbers either way
the numbers speak for themselves during
his nba career the big
aristotle has the fourth highest career
earnings in
nba history raking in a cool
300 million dollars shaq's resume
includes
four nba championships two retired
jerseys
and an nba record 12.5
broken backwards and today the man has
built a
business empire after the nba the big
aristotle transitioned
into the big ipo and he follows a strict
investment philosophy
invest in what you love he only gets
involved he personally likes the company
and it seems like shaq personally likes
to eat he's owned 155
five guys restaurants which is almost
like 800 guys
he's earned mad though endorsing papa
john's
and he's got a dozen auntie annie's how
about them pretzels
shaq collects food spots like trading
cards and for his sweet tooth
he's the global spokesperson for krispy
kreme and he also gets paid
the dunk oreos but don't you trip if he
needs to cut weight
he can practice shack foo in one of his
24-hour fitness gyms that he owns he's
also
all about cooking up the beats he's
released four rap albums
with his first shack diesel going
platinum
and dj diesel has played at coachella
ultra lollapalooza and for the right
price he might dj your bar mitzvah
the big fella has even written a
children's book which is the only time
anyone's ever called him
little shaq and the big diesel loves the
big screen he's done movies
and now he owns movie theaters plus he
gets a million dollars a year for his
role
on inside the nba on tnt where he and
sir
charles get paid to shack the fool on
their
emmy award-winning show and if you think
shaq is working too hard
don't you worry he gets millions from
gold bond
and icy hot to make him feel better the
man is
chilling he's driving around in his free
buick he's covered
by the general and his cars stay fresh
and clean
at one of his 150 car washes and if he
needs a little vacay
he's the chief fun officer at carnival
cruise lines
plus he's got shack sneakers shack suits
and shack jewelry at zales he ain't
going to jared
this dude is putting up numbers on and
off
the court and the big ipo is a giant
in silicon valley his first big
investment
was in google which he bought in 2004
at 75 bucks a share google is now at 24
hundred dollars a share today
and he says my only regret is that i
wish i would have bought more
yeah i bet shaq shaq's the tallest
minority owner of the sacramento kings
and the 2018 he became the general
manager of the kingsguard gaming of the
nba
2k esports league shaq cardone he
created the o'neill group in 2006 to
develop real estate projects
and he co-founded majority an ad agency
focused on diversity and shanks packs
shaq took
fitness brand beachbody public in a
three billion dollar merger
and shaq has made other investments and
you know little small unknown companies
that you probably never heard of
like lift vitamin water and ring shaq
says he loved the doorbell camera home
security system
so much that he tracked down the
inventor of ring
bought a part of the business and even
starred in their commercials
then in 2019 shaq got a sweet piece of
the pie when amazon purchased ring
for over a billion dollars now speaking
of amazon
the diesel says he overheard jeff bezos
say
that he makes investments based on if
it's going to change
people's lives and once shaq started
doing that strategy
he says i think i probably quadrupled
what i'm worth
good on you shaq and shaq is in a
one-man operation he's got this guy
perry rogers a corporate consultant
and sports management ceo that has
helped shaq manage his business since
shaq says he's one of the five people
that he takes advice
and criticism from keep your circle
small now let's talk about
shaq jupiter shaq is big in general we
all know that but he's huge
on education he says i don't care what
you do in your life
if you're an educated person no one can
take anything from you
he studied business at lsu he scored an
online mba degree from university of
phoenix
and a doctorate at bear university down
in miami and now dr shak holds strategic
meetings called the shack summit where
his business partners make
15 minute presentations for potential
new deals
and endorsements it's the shack tank now
despite this insane level of success
shaq remains a man of the people for the
people that can't afford the pricier
kicks
shaq sells his reebok shoes for 20 to 40
bucks
because he says there are more people
that make regular money
than there are people who make a whole
bunch of money well said shaq
now a guy was putting on a wedding ring
on layaway and shaq said
don't worry buddy i got you i own part
of zales and an old lady whose house
burned down
she was shopping for a new couch shaq
said let me furnish the entire place for
you
for 30 grand and this one time shaq got
traded he dropped 70k
at walmart just to move into a new place
it didn't do it at barney's
not at pier one my man went to walmart
and got it done
think about the savings my two cents
i'm on team shaq shaq's all about saving
to invest shaq saved 75 percent of his
income
and owes it to a moment where he met a
guy that showed him a piece of paper now
he says
this is a hundred bucks after ripping
the piece of paper in half
the man told o'neill smart people invest
this 50
and then they have this 50 to live on
however wealthy people
take half of this 50 and put that away
so o'neill started doing that now he
encourages all investors to follow the
same strategy
to save and invest most of your money
and then you live
on what's left so what can you take from
all this now shaq said it best
it's not about how much money you make
the question is are you educated enough
to keep it
so shaq is are you
thanks for watching this video on what
shaq did with the money
now let me ask you if you had 400
million dollars
what would you do let me know in the
comments below and remember
save that money we talk is money